[Music]
so
good morning everybody it's seven
o'clock abusing british values the home
secretary singles out the asylum system
as a merry-go-round that's been
exploited and links it to the liverpool
attack more on that with the
international trade secretary and marie
trevelyan shortly plus how to head off
headlines of sleaze as the pm reveals
his plans for mp's second jobs plus the
shadow leader of the house of com of
commons thangam debonair
is it enough and as the scandal
engulfing cricket widens we'll talk to
the former england player amjad khan
also
snakes are a pain we meet the man trying
to tackle ibiza's reptile problem with
his bare hands and
[Music]
that's your ear worm for today ladies
and gentlemen he's an 80s legend reborn
as a successful las vegas star now matt
goss is back with a new album we'll chat
with him later it's wednesday the 17th
of november
asylum system under attack with reports
that the home secretary
has said the level of pull attack is a
reflection of a dysfunctional
merry-go-round that's been exploited
how much will families be squeezed this
christmas live this hour will bring you
the latest inflation figures with the
rise expected
cricket crisis and more accusations of
racism as the government calls on the
england and wales cricket board to take
action
cleaning up bots is a rebellion brewing
some tory back benches criticize the
prime minister's plans to restrict
second jobs
border block water cannon deployed as
thousands of migrants try to reach
poland from belarus where there live
and we'll go live to la palma as the
volcano continues to bring havoc to
those living on the island just look at
those pictures my goodness
[Music]
good morning it's been reported this
morning that the home secretary says the
man suspected of causing the explosion
outside a liverpool hospital was able to
exploit what she calls britain's
dysfunctional asylum system pretty patel
described the current setup as a
complete merry-go-round martin brunt is
standing by for us with more marcin good
morning to you
good morning kaye the police
investigation has continued overnight
some searching
still going on but uh there are things
the police still don't know but they are
making good progress
they say their suspect is dead there
appears to be no evidence of a support
network
so while all of that
is continuing the story is turning
political um edmond swalemean was
re-established yesterday a failed asylum
seeker he came from somewhere in the
middle east here
in 2014 and a year later had his asylum
application rejected he then appealed
and that appeal was also turned down now
the home secretary pretty patel is using
this bombing as an illustration of why
she is right
to reform the asylum system she's
embarked on that there's a new bill
going through parliament sometime soon
and on a on a plane to washington last
night where she's making a visit to the
u s she spoke to reporters and said this
the case in liverpool
was a complete reflection of how
dysfunctional how broken the system has
been in the past it's a complete
merry-go-round and it has been exploited
yesterday when we were speaking to
police and home
office officials and unofficially nobody
was happy to talk about
the bomber's current status
okay for now martin thanks so much
indeed last few minutes last few seconds
we've just got the latest inflation
figures
for you they are now
up to 4.2 percent
uh in the 12 months to october 2021
consumer price index cpr rose by 4.2
in the 12 months to october 21 um up
from 3.1 in september the trade
secretary international trade secretary
and marie trevallion is here um i
suppose that means that uh public sector
workers will have to get at least four
percent just to stand still with a pay
rise so i know that the uh chancellor
spoke about this in his budget and
the figures looking forward to identify
that there would be a slight increase
in
inflation in the months ahead because of
a number of the pressures that have come
through as the economies uh have all
kicked off again post covert and he uh
noted at the time uh that department's
uh settlements would be uh there so that
they could at a departmental level have
those conversations with their
workforces and that i'm sure will happen
in the months ahead and the independent
review bodies will be able to
work with their departmental uh teams to
put forward the right proposition
i mean i've said to your colleagues in
the past and i'm not very good at maths
but i mean even i can figure out that it
needs to be at least four percent just
to stand still so indeed that's what the
pair of your bodies are there for to
work uh with their own cohort of public
sector workers and work with the
departmental teams to get the right so
i'm sure we'll see that coming through
in the months ahead okay talk to me
about liverpool if you would we were all
shocked about um what happened we've
heard from the home secretary overnight
um she says
uh that what happened in liverpool is
the result of a dysfunctional asylum
system is that what you think
so what we saw was was appalling uh
thank goodness that uh the drive of the
taxi wasn't wasn't more hurt and i think
we're all very grateful need for his
bravery and his quick uh thinking uh and
uh hopefully he will be fully recovered
at least from his physical injuries soon
i think uh what we see in the home
sector obviously has spoken about it and
i'm sure we'll continue to as more uh
evidence as this is looked at comes
through is the challenge of ensuring
that those uh who are asylum seekers who
come to our country because they need
our support our care and the opportunity
to live a safe life in the uk
should get here in a safe way so the
huge amount of work that she's doing to
stop uh gangs uh moving people around
and abu abusing uh their vulnerability
is something that she's very focused on
fighting so that we can make sure that
as the kind and welcoming country that
we always have been and continue to be
we make sure that those who really need
our care and want to be play their full
part in uk society are the ones that
come to the uk and receive our support
but do you believe what happened in
liverpool is the result of a
dysfunctional asylum system
so as the home secretary has already
discussed and she said it herself that
you know in the past this system hasn't
been working and she's been working
incredibly hard in the last couple of
years to really shake that down and make
sure that it is coherent works you know
works well and effectively really
importantly so that those uh who are
genuine asylum seekers and indeed who
want to play a full and positive part in
our communities in the uk across the uk
uh are the people that are coming in
that we provide that support
so you're agreeing with the home
secretary with the home secretary
so i think her her point is uh well
maybe that's what your opinion is well
so my opinion is that i want to see a
system that works uh that makes sure
that those who are most vulnerable and
indeed who
want to come here and be a part a fully
functioning part of our uk wonderful uk
society are able to get here safely
not being abused by
those gangs who are taking advantage of
their of their vulnerability so that's
that's what we want to make sure yeah
i'm talking particularly so i'm i'm uh
obviously not uh cited on the detail of
the case and where the home secretary is
but i trust that her judgment uh of that
situation uh and the time frame in which
uh the bomber in question came to the uk
is one at a time when the system uh
didn't work as effectively as it is now
under her leadership are you taking her
word for it that the attack in liverpool
um was um directly connected to the
asylum system in the uk
so as i say i don't know the detail of
the case but you're taking her well i
think her point that the system
historically had been dysfunctional and
wasn't uh assessing uh in as uh with as
much uh care as it needed to and to make
sure as i say that those who are uh
coming here and getting us our support
through our assignment system are those
who are the most vulnerable and who want
to be a full part of our uk society when
they get here yeah that would suggest
that the the whole case in liverpool has
been
investigated and that's the end of it
because otherwise why would she why
would she say that well as the
homosexual she has a great deal more
information at her fingertips and indeed
more widely about the depth of the
system than
those of us who aren't working in the
home office yeah what we need to be
concerned about though is demonizing all
asylum seekers as potential terrorists
well precisely the opposite to that and
that's her point which is uh that for
those who come here uh who we are able
to provide asylum for and who wish to
play a full uh personal society of those
that we want to see and we want to
support them and we have some great
systems certainly uh in
northumberland in my patch we have uh
taken in a large number of syrian
families over the last few years and
they are wonderful wonderful part of our
community now uh and you know their
children are now uh thoroughly part of
the school system and very much uh you
know northumbrians adoptees and i think
that's the sort of that's continues to
be what uh the home sector and the prime
minister's focus is to make sure that
that support is there for those
families and individuals who are genuine
asylum seekers back to liverpool though
if i may um as far as the mayor of
liverpool is concerned we had him on the
program yesterday he says the city won't
be divided there's a lot of nastiness
online he said that's trying hatred on
social media as he put it how does the
home secretary's words about um what
happened in liverpool uh being as a
direct result of the dysfunctional
asylum system help to unite the people
of liverpool this morning so i couldn't
believe i think some of the
poison that uh social media can create
uh is um beyond unhelpful and can
trigger all sorts of bad behavior and
it's great to see
the voice of liverpool as we would
expect speaking as one saying
this was a traumatic and appalling event
but uh the town and all its communities
will stand together against violence
and i think that's
the home secretary's words very clearly
about the historic nature of the system
and that now uh
she and her team have been working very
hard to make sure that it works better
and fighting against those gangs who are
trying to abuse the vulnerability of
asylum seekers and their communities
trying uh to reach a safe harbor okay
you say historic um system nature of the
system but i mean you guys have been in
power for 11 years
so as i say the home secretary's been
imposed uh for a couple of years i
suppose
and her work has been very has been very
focused on that well as i say i don't uh
i wasn't involved in that and i think
this is a continuing challenge one of
the really big challenges and we see it
obviously some of the gangs abusing the
system as they put vulnerable people
into small boats trying to cross the
channel amongst other places and we've
seen it over the years
across the mediterranean those most
vulnerable families and indeed young
people who are seeking a safe life
somewhere safe
across across european countries or
indeed in the uk we need to make sure
that
as the uk we want to bring in those who
are genuinely vulnerable and need that
support and can be full part of of our
wonderful
uk's uh communities wherever uh they end
up making their home here so i think
that continues to be the focus and that
she is driving towards a system which
can ensure that we have uh control of
our borders so that we can make those
decisions uh in a rational and
compassionate way nevertheless how can
you be critical of the historic nature
of the system which is letting in
potential terrorists in the words of the
home secretary when you guys have been
in power for 11 years as i said so whose
fault is it so the home secretary uh
sits in the home office and looks after
that and when she came into post she was
determined to make sure that those uh
criminal gangs who were abusing the
system were they considered so i think
government not doing that before so
that's continued to be a developed case
i think as we've seen some appalling uh
you know very very uh big uh migration
movements because of war in a number of
countries uh the movements have changed
and indeed these criminal gangs who are
abusing uh the vulnerability of those
have moved and changed and like all
criminal gangs whatever it is that
they're up to uh it's always a bit of a
game of cat and mouse and i think the
home secretary has been very very robust
and she came into politics
who are you criticizing for the historic
nature of the system then whose fault is
it
so the system is is complex like so many
government systems and i think at the
home secretary's folks when she came to
post was to make it uh as streamlined as
impactful as possible because she has
always been very clear that one of the
so javid wasn't up to the job well i
don't think i'm sure he did a very good
job but i think uh when the home
secretary president has actually came in
uh and because we have seen this huge
rise in criminal gangs abusing the
vulnerability of those who are seeking
safe harbor
that she has thrown the full weight
of her focus behind that to make sure
that we are able to give
safe harbor to those who most need it
many other countries obviously do the
same
and that that is our focus
is that what you're saying
but i think i think that i think the
point that the home secretary has made
is that the system has has had to become
more robust as the gangs have uh used
migration in a much more uh
aggressive way for their own financial
gain and that that has had to be a much
greater focus and that the present home
secretary has uh spent a lot of time
pushing it forward
well i think we've seen big increases in
it in the last few years as a result of
these
terrible and devastating impacts of war
across the world indeed so not least
afghanistan we saw what happened there
in august talk to me about sleaze why
have we seen a u-turn from the pm on
second jobs
so i was really pleased to see uh the
pm's uh letter yesterday which sets out
two of the key issues which were raised
in a 2018 uh report putting out a whole
series of uh propositions uh i think the
pm's uh point is well made that i mean
these this is obviously run by the
commission it's not it's not uh
determined by government uh but his
suggestion that the question of uh jobs
that relate to uh political consultancy
so explaining to uh those uh you know a
business uh how parliament works or
indeed how uh how the machinery works is
something that is not appropriate whilst
you're a serving mp okay and indeed that
uh the main focus of your of your time
spent should be focusing on your work as
an mp and clearly you know you might be
chris branch and you might be a
brilliant author you might in your spare
time write books uh you might be maria
caulfield an amazing nurse who does
shifts at the weekend in her local
hospital and so on but that actually if
it's uh related to your skill set that's
fine but if you're taking your time away
from brilliant access got it that's the
broad brush i've got several
supplementaries let's fire through them
what is reasonable limits on second jobs
which is the prime minister's wording
what is a reasonable limit is that the
reasonable number of hours or a
reasonable amount of money that you're
earning
so i certainly don't think it relates to
cash because that's uh that's not a
relevant metric depends what you do like
all of us there's you know you do jobs
for different reasons i think it's going
to be about uh the focus of your uh you
know they say effort you know uh
neither you or i and i work a 40-hour
week in the jobs that we do uh but we
know when we've uh you know decided that
we've had a long dedication i think the
point and that came from the commission
which is uh the question about
reasonableness is one that would you
know that the next question will be how
do we how do we assess that and i think
reasonable is something that's
understood so uh you know the chris
bryant's author in his spare time we've
got several defenses let's rush through
them uh because of course the vote is
today so other mps will want to know who
decides which second job is appropriate
well so again what what the prime
minister set out and this was in the
commission uh report back in 2018 uh is
to identify that if it's something to do
with uh
your workers and a piece of explaining
as a political opportunity who's going
to make that decision well so i think i
think the uh conversation which we'll
discuss will be whether that sits with
the standards commissioner uh or indeed
a you know a wide court the the
committee i mean that will be a
discussion for okay for parliamentarians
to have i think what we want is someone
uh you know who is able to apply you
know a rational filter so potentially
catherine stone um will there be an
appeal process if you if she says
something she says no absolutely not
that's not counted who will you appeal
to should there be an appeal process
because as we know there was a bit of an
issue with appeals yes well that i think
that's exactly to your point that's a
really important question which i have
no doubt many colleagues will bring up
uh which is should we be thinking about
having a proper appeal
so well
all all parliamentarians will put
forward and support uh or indeed not
support uh a proposition that's put
forward in due course the vote today is
to is to you know put this into into the
next stage of the presidency decided
there's an appeal though who will decide
uh who will judge an appeal
well indeed that would be part of the
that would be uh part of the discussions
that colleagues will want to have with
the committee on standards to make sure
that if we bring one in which and that
india as you say is one of the reasons
why they were uh discussions and
anxieties over the owen patterson case
is uh that it's something that
colleagues have have confidence in
because i think that's important so at
this stage we don't know what it's
actually going to mean as far as
reasonable limits and we don't know what
a second job might mean or not mean we
don't know who's going to be in charge
necessarily and we don't know who's
going to be in charge of the appeal
process if you necessarily want to
appeal against a decision that's made
about your second job and the votes
today
the vote is to move forward for the next
stage and this and then the the
standards committee uh uh and the
commissioner will uh go away and bring
forward proposition so this isn't this
isn't uh uh a constant there is no
well you'd you'd love us and i wouldn't
we all love an instant and complete
solution uh overnight this is an
opportunity for the questions that i
just came up with off the top of my head
the cab on the way
i mean seriously because you like but
that's the point uh this is an
opposition day debate where we will
discuss some of these issues and
colleagues will have an opportunity on
both sides of the house to raise their
concerns and indeed hopefully their
suggestions on what yeah isn't it well
welcome to parliament uh the the
complexity of how our system works never
ceases to amaze all of us opposition day
debates uh will bring the opportunity
for this conversation to be had more
fully and then uh the parliamentary
house systems will be able to come
forward with something uh which we can
continue to move because i think an
appeals process personally i think is
one that we want to think about bringing
in i think that's important we are out
of time but i just want to ask you about
caroline knocks um thoughts for her this
morning so we have a robust uh system if
there are uh concerns within the
conservative party about that and if
caroline obviously wanted to raise that
um
hammering on social media i cannot read
out some of the stuff that she had
i'm just not going to read that out of
there
um but you know that is a direct result
of us standing up to be counted well
indeed and i'm very very glad uh that
anyone stands out to candidate if uh
this sort of uh as she suggests uh
behavior goes on it should always be
called out to be investigated yet though
won't you i'm guessing well actually i
will leave caroline to work with a party
on that but uh we have a robust system
in place and i hope very much that she
will uh be able to uh work that through
with the with the party machine but more
widely this is something that you know
all of us who are women not only in
political life in all sorts of life have
for far too long had to tolerate uh the
sort of casual sexism uh the wandering
hand that is completely unacceptable and
most men are as horrified as you or i
are what would you have done in that
situation i mean if you've done it at
the time i'd have probably slapped him
um which arguably isn't a better
response either but it would mean it
would have been an instinctive response
uh from me i think caroline will have
showed great uh you know personal
restraint if she uh quietly you know
moved away i mean i don't know about you
but i'm in an age where you sit down at
dinner and a hand would suddenly appear
on my knee you know you're like excuse
me gentleman on my left who i don't know
could you remove your hand from my knee
that was that sort of casual sexism was
not uncommon it is much less common
thank goodness now but we do have much
better and robust systems of any woman
uh who receives uh that sort of uh
abusive behavior
from someone absolutely should feel
confident that she can stand up both
face them down but also have the support
of those around her to make sure that
the abuser in question does not do that
it is not acceptable
and it's not acceptable whether it's to
a woman or to a young man who are more
vulnerable and indeed uh you know less
able to speak out and we have much
better systems in place to protect them
and i would always uh call anyone who
feels uh under that sort of pressure to
speak up and we will all stand by them
here here it's good to talk to you thank
you for joining
and just a reminder if you are heading
out this morning then of course you can
take us with you um via
our online services of course
skynews.com you can check out the blog
there as well if you would like to and
you can uh in just a couple of minutes
time um um busy uh fixing up our
twitters and tweets for you just at the
moment and the headlines from the
interview that we did will be uh online
in just a moment at sky news at k burley
more on that breaking news we brought to
you at the top of the programme and now
and that is the latest inflation figures
which are at our business correspondent
helen and smith is here
four point 4.1
percent okay four point two percent the
consumer price index is what this is so
it's the cost of a standard basket of
goods and services and it's gone up four
point two percent uh in october compared
to what it was last year now it's a big
number it's really really significant to
put it in some sort of context in
september inflation was about 3.1
percent and there was sort of murmurings
of concern about that it's about the
highest in a decade that we've seen
really confirming i think what a lot of
families will have felt at home in the
month of october that the cost of living
really really is spiraling and remember
the month of october as well was the
month where the furlough scheme came to
an end that temporary uplift and
universal credit came to an end where
there's tax risers as well that families
are facing the hike in national
insurance so a big cost of living crisis
now why is it so significant there's a
couple of uh lots of things are going up
there's a couple of real key ones that
are pushing it firstly energy we've
heard so much about that soaring
wholesale cost of energy and in the
month of october off gem
raised uh the energy price cap so lots
of families saw a 12 increase in the
price of their energy the other thing k
was fuel fuel prices at the pump we all
know have gone up hugely at their record
highs at the moment so there's a couple
of the reasons this will all raise a bit
of uh more questions about whether those
um uh whether the bank of england will
put up interest rates that's one of the
tools that would take some of the heat
um out of this market there was a lot of
surprise when they didn't do that at the
beginning of november a lot of eyes will
now be on them as to whether they do
that they've got a tricky balance to
strike though because keeping interest
rates low they're currently at historic
lows uh is part of the reason uh that
they're part of the tools they're using
to keep the economy sort of uh in check
as it recovers uh after the pandemic uh
the chancellor of the exchequer rishi
sunax said uh said something on this
this morning uh he said uh many
countries are experiencing higher
inflation as we recover from covid and
we know people are facing pressures with
the cost of living which is why we are
taking action worth more than 4.2
billion pounds to help them we're
getting people into work uh progress to
keep more of what they earn through our
plan for jobs uh and sorry i've lost oh
no here we go sorry i've got the rest of
it here
we're keeping uh we're helping people
get into work uh progress and keep more
of what they earn through our plans for
jobs and by effectively cutting taxes
for workers receiving universal credit
we're also providing more immediate
support including through the 500
million pound household support fund for
the most vulnerable families fuel and
alcohol duty freezes and the energy
price cap there were lots of things in
his budget
okay that really tried to address some
of those cost of living crisis problems
but families will really be feeling this
big big jump in inflation for sure okay
helena thanks very much indeed thanks a
lot immediate analysis there from helena
moore in the next hour
meantime take immediate action that's
the call from the prime minister
following allegations of years of racist
abuse by former cricketer azim rafiq he
told a parliamentary committee the
english cricket is institutionally
racist yorkshire county cricket club
along with current and former players
are now facing serious allegations becky
cottrell reports
rafiq gets his man alas his performance
on the pitch is what azeem rafiq wanted
to be remembered for but now he has a
bigger mission off the pitch exposing
the racism that ruined his time at
yorkshire cricket and made him suicidal
felt isolated
humiliated at times
constant use of the word
i mean 2017 pre-season tour we were in a
in a place and gary balance walks over
and goes why are you talking to him you
know he's a
um or
he's not a shake he's got no oil
and this happened in front of teammates
it happened in front of coaching staff
his former teammate gary balance has
already admitted using the highly
offensive p word towards rafiq saying
there was no intended malice
rafiq spoke of racism as the norm at
headingley but said there were deeply
personal and painful moments too when i
lost my son i went you know what hold on
a minute
i've seen other players who
have family tragedies and get support
beyond measure and i've just carried my
son
from the hospital
to the graveyard and
how i'm getting treated here is not
right and
to me it became very clear that even
myself i'd been looking the other way
and there's a real problem here not just
yorkshire throughout the country
rafiq says the abuse was also going on
at his local club when he wasn't much
older than these boys training in
bradford
many of them dream of turning
professional but they're alarmed by what
they've heard
this really doesn't help like kids like
us to progress it doesn't it doesn't
boost our confidence it lowers our
confidence
and just makes me really disappointed
for seeing what's happening right now
ayan asan is 12 years old and would love
to play for yorkshire he was shocked by
the allegations
it's made me think about like why people
do that at such a like high level
because
it takes effort to get there and he's um
rafiq he tried hard to get there so like
he shouldn't like be
having to face like bullying all this
sort of stuff
these children feel the weight of the
words of a british asian player who says
racism cost him his career
they're hoping changes will come out at
this moment and make all the difference
to their futures becky cottrell sky news
bradford
[Music]
shing is standing by for us hello to you
good morning my goodness me and the
headlines this morning on all of the
newspapers reflecting what happened
good morning kate that's right a number
of newspapers saying that yesterday was
cricket's day of shame azim rafiq
speaking in front of that select
committee visibly emotional what a
number of points spoke about his
experiences of racism
beginning with his time as a youth
player where he allegedly had red wine
poured down his throat to a number of
instances in which the p word was used
and teammates allegedly stood on by and
watched this happening because of his
words yesterday cricket is now under the
spotlight with a number of people
putting into question the sport's
governing bodies including rafiq himself
who said that he felt let down by the
ecb and the professional cricketers
association after going public with his
allegations last year and another person
who's called for the cricket authorities
to take immediate action is the prime
minister boris johnson who tweeted this
yesterday
brave testimony from azeem rafiq i
commend him for speaking out there is no
excuse for racism anywhere in society
and we expect england cricket and
yorkshire ccc to take immediate action
in response to these allegations i think
it's quite clear now that this is a
story that goes beyond headingly it goes
beyond yorkshire cricket it's put the
entire sport of cricket under the
underneath the spotlight and there will
be serious questions about how the
cricketing authorities deal with racism
okay thanks very much for the update
thanks a lot still to come on the
programme for you this morning following
the devastating evidence of racism in
cricket from haseem rafiq we'll get the
thoughts of retired international
cricketer amjad khan
we'll also look over the latest
inflation data and explain what it
actually means for you with andrew
sentence former member of the bank of
england committee monetary policy
committee
we'll meet the british man who's trying
to stop the mediterranean island of
ibiza from becoming overrun by snakes
dean gallagher will join us later
and also this morning have a look at
these pictures my goodness me the
volcano in la palma still making its
presence felt after now almost two
months of eruption local news reported
over the weekend that the volcano has
claimed its first victim a 72 year old
man who died at his family home
in the exclusion zone scientists think
the lava could keep coming for yet
another month
mother nature looking at like she's not
going to give up the island any time
soon look at what happened here one
person's died two missing after severe
flooding in canada british columbia was
the worst affected area with two days of
torrential rail rain rather shutting
down roads and railways
and an update on a story we brought you
yesterday morning on the program joanna
lumley talked to us about the use of
large underwater explosions remember to
clear the seabed around britain
well the blasts generally take place
during the construction of wind farms
and when underwater cables are laid
just hours after our interview the
government produced a new policy
proposal saying it wanted
for companies to find alternative
methods of clearance
yesterday joanna told us why she was
opposed to the explosions
the sea blast the high is called high
order which is the great explosions you
have to clear the seabed of the masses
of munitions left over from the second
world war what they do is they simply
blow them up so there's an enormous
explosion it uh damages the seabed
irreparably it sends out toxic particles
into the ocean kills the fish
and almost most importantly it damages
the sonar of whales and dolphins which
means that they become stranded they
can't find their pods they can't feed
they quite often die or they just get
lost in stuff
and as we were saying it would appear
hours later that the government has had
a change of heart now officials in new
york say their new year fireworks
celebrations will take place this year
the event will be open to the public as
normal but everyone will have to show
proof of vaccination to get into times
square
latest covert data in the uk for you
let's have a look 37
243 new cases
there's also been a further 214 deaths
that brings the total number of deaths
reported within 28 days of a positive
test
to 143 thousand
159 people who have died from covid here
in the uk
quick look at the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
mild this week rain and gales in the
north at times but sunday looks much
colder for now it's a mostly dry start
if rather chilly but the windy north has
showers especially the northwest
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
coming up we're going to be um letting
you know what anne marie trevelyan
for the government just spoke to her
about 20 minutes or so ago what she
would have done
if someone had smacked her bottom at
tory party conference as allegedly
happened to caroline nooks will have
more on what she had to say fascinating
response also we'll speak to former
international cricketer amgen khan
following the devastating evidence of
racism in cricket from azeem rafiq that
to come
[Music]
and again the trade secretary has given
her support to conservative mp caroline
knox who tells sky news that she was
inappropriately touched by the father of
the prime minister stanley johnson has
told us he had no recollection of miss
notes and no reply and marie trevelyan
told us how she would have reacted if
she had experienced inappropriate
behavior
what you've done in that situation i
mean if you've done that at the time i'd
have probably slapped him um which
arguably isn't a better response either
but it would be it would have been an
instinctive response uh from me i think
caroline would have showed great uh you
know personal restraint if she uh
quietly you know moved away i mean i
don't know about you but i'm gonna have
an age where you sit down at dinner and
a hand would suddenly appear on my knee
you know you're like excuse me gentleman
on my left who i don't know could you
remove your hand from my knee that was
that sort of casual sexism was not
uncommon it is much less common thank
goodness now but we do have much better
and robust systems than any woman
who receives
that sort of abusive behavior
from someone absolutely should feel
confident that she can stand up
both face them down but also
have the support of those around her to
make sure that
the abuser in question does not do that
it is not acceptable
strong words tomorrow yeah very strong
words and interesting that a cabinet
minister is rowing in to support
caroline noakes who made this accusation
on sky news yesterday that the prime
minister's father stanley johnson
inappropriately touched her at a
conservative party conference in 2003
followed then by a journalist at the new
statesman magazine saying something
similar happened to her two years ago
stanley johnson denies knowing miss
noakes
downing street officially yesterday
wouldn't comment on any of this stanley
johnson is of course not an mp not an
elected politician and they said this
was an individual case they didn't want
to get into it trying to distance
themselves from it and suggest it's not
none of the prime minister's concern
although labour and others have called
for an investigation so interesting to
see cabinet ministers rowing in to
support miss knox although she said she
would have slapped him um what caroline
knox was saying is that as a candidate
trying to climb the ladder she didn't do
anything and then later felt ashamed and
now feels the need to speak out for
people who can't in that moment do
anything sure um we also heard from the
the minister representing the government
this morning um about her views and what
pretty patella has been saying overnight
yes pretty patel has been telling
journalists who are on a plane to the
u.s with her that
the case in liverpool of the liverpool
bomber which of course the police have
only just started investigating is a
case of our dysfunctional and broken
asylum system and she says this
merry-go-round of people uh being
rejected and then trying to apply
again
anne marie trevelyan didn't
wholeheartedly agree with that but she
said the home secretary may know more
about his motivations than she did but
going to be very controversial those
comments given police have only just
started investigating the motive of
course and and the idea that um asylum
seekers um
are coming to commit terrorism in some
way is obviously as you put to andromeda
valiant in the view of many people is
not going to be a way to bring the city
of liverpool together okay um tomorrow's
take nine o'clock see you then looking
forward to it thank you
meantime the prime minister says the
england and wales cricket board must
respond following as in refuge evidence
to parliament of highly offensive racist
language and what he called inhuman
treatment boris johnson said officials
need to take immediate action
joined nigh by the lawyer and former
professional cricketer amjad khan hello
to you i'm jud khan thank you for
joining us on the programme this morning
what did you make of the uh testimony
yesterday
well it's been interesting couple of
days doesn't it um i think
on one hand we've been
mourning the win
the australia's win of the world cup but
still celebrating the qriket has been a
fantastic tournament and on the other
hand we've been listening to this guy
from barnsley who said that
cricket almost cost him his life
i found the testimony compelling i found
it very factual i found him very
credible
and obviously he was it was very
emotional
and i think it sort of
it proves once and for all there's a
systemic problem
what's your experience been
um i think i was i've been i think i've
been very fortunate i wasn't subjected
to any of that
um but that shouldn't deter from the
fact that there is a
there's a big problem i think um
the last few days a lot of
ex-players of asian background have have
reached out to me
i think
it proves once and for all that this has
been going on and even though it didn't
go on
with me it didn't have an effect on me
it doesn't mean that uh other peoples
weren't subjected to this
indeed and absolutely not suggesting
that for one moment i just wondered if
you wonder
you often must wonder yourself why you
didn't um why you weren't subject to the
same sort of
offensive behavior and comments that
other players have been
um i think
i was
i was fortunate i was in two very very
good clubs
and
at canton sussex and
i was with
good people
i think the environment there was good i
think there was a tradition of
salvation players coming in overseas
players
and i wasn't a victim to that but um as
i said i've been contacted by
an ex-county player who's in a dispute
with the ecb at the moment i've been
contacted by
another high-profile
cricketer who wants to come forward
um another county player on the verge of
coming forward plus someone at grassroot
level who who also wants to come forward
so
i mean there is a systemic problem that
we can't deny it i don't think we are
but
but the last few days has made us very
aware of that
and is there a common denominator
between all of those um gents that have
come forward to you
well i think first and foremost
these guys they want to tell their
stories and i think the validity of
their claims they want to have dealt
with
transparently and openly i think they
want the stories heard
and i think that's the least we can do
to these guys
and how do the stories that you've heard
from these four guys um
compare and contrast to what we heard
from i see rafiq yesterday
um i think a couple of them especially
one of the players um
his story does remind me of azeem
because azim not only tell tells the
stories of racial bullying he also just
talks about the bullying in general
um and that shouldn't be tolerated
either um so it's a mixture of the two
but the others are talking about it
being a systemic problem they felt that
their race kept them back
um
so there are common denominators
absolutely
and is it
players that their their teammates that
weren't supporting them is it is that
the challenge or was it that the clubs
weren't supporting them or is it both
um it was both um i think a few of them
were subjected to stuff from the
teammates but i think what was most
hurtful to them was
that the clubs that they were at weren't
protecting them and were complicit in
this abuse
and i think the reason that they're
they're reaching out to me is because
i'm not an asian background i now have a
legal background um i'm still in the
game as well
and i think they just
they're unsure of the constitutionality
of this and how
due process works
and i think they're contacting me
because of my legal background so i can
sort of guide them in the direction
because a few of them have also lost
faith in the pca as azim said which is
really unfortunate because i think pca
do a lot of good work and they've lost a
bit of faith on the ecb and i think a
reparation
has to take place there because you
can't fracture the game like that
how do you see um given that they're
asking your advice what do you see
happening next for those four players
as i said i think some sort of
reparation and if i can play a role in
that i mean i'm not going to represent
them legally they're my friends um but
if i i think after probably this
interview i will be getting in touch
with some people probably through the
ecb and the pca
and
yeah figure out what due process is how
do we do this so it is fair on these
guys who have obviously suffered
but also repair
the damage that is done and start
repairing that but i think as azim said
the first thing is you have to listen to
these guys they want due process they
want to know that they can they will be
listened to
and they won't be miscredited
do they still play
yes at some level yeah
okay
and they haven't been put off the game
of cricket by the way that they have
been treated is it is it a minority of
players that they feel have treated them
inappropriately and they still want to
play or have the some of them just
completely lost heart and hope with the
game
i think
they haven't they love the game we love
the game
and it's often our first love
um
i think it's very difficult to fall out
of love with the game but they have lost
faith in the system
and as i said before that needs to be
repaired um because that will literally
break the game in half if this continues
um but some of them have been through
what azim went through they had to go
find themselves again
pick themselves up get involved in the
game again but the scars are still there
and
credit to azeem because he's put
like he's
he's given guys an opportunity and a
chance to come forward with these things
i haven't purposefully impressed you on
the names because you know they you
don't have their authority to do that at
this stage but if they do want to talk
to us um either anonymously or otherwise
at some stage then of course we would be
um very keen to hear what they have to
say for now thank you very much indeed
for joining us thank you
uh returning to another one of our top
stories latest inflation figures have
been released this morning what does a
man who used to be a former member of
the bank of england's monastery policy
committee think about that that's
andrew's sentence mr sentence thanks for
joining us on the programme what do you
make of the latest figures good morning
well they're not unexpected because um
we were expecting inflation to go over
four percent the figure this morning for
the measure that the bank of england
looks at is 4.2
um there are some other scary figures
those have been released and the old
retail prices index is going up at six
percent
and the prices of goods leaving
factories are going up at eight percent
and i think what that tells us is this
is not the end of the inflation surge um
that we're seeing and i think as we get
into the new year we may well see
inflation going up to five to six
percent uh which is nearly three times
the bank of england's target
so what does it mean for mortgages and
loans and salaries
well the bank of england uh ducked the
challenge at its november meeting um of
making a very small rise in interest
rates
um i do think we will see interest rates
rise um perhaps
in the december meeting but possibly
more likely in the early part of next
year
but interest rates are not going to go
up very sharply
partly because the bank of england is is
being quite reluctant to to push them up
and so um
yes mortgage rates may go up a little
bit
but not in a dramatic way i think
what does it mean for our economic
recovery
well the economic recovery uh is
continuing we've had a big bounce coming
back out of the pandemic and the
lockdowns
we can't expect the economy to bowl
along at the same rate as it has done
over the last six or nine months or so
as we've come out of
some very severe restrictions
i don't think we should expect a very
rapid economic recovery once that
bounces as fed through into the figures
but we've had indicators that show that
the economy is in in quite good shape in
uh terms of the labor market we had that
yesterday
with record vacancies employment rising
um unemployment coming down
so i think the economy should be
resilient to rises in interest rates as
long as those rises are gradual and well
communicated by the bank of england's
monetary policy committee
yeah been down for donkey's years
haven't they one wonders once uh the
mortgage rates start to go up how long
that might be in that trajectory for
well they've been down at a real record
low recently 0.1
um before the pandemic they were at
three-quarters of a percent
so going up to somewhere around about
one percent shouldn't be too much of a
shock for people
um
but uh the question is what then happens
next
but i still think that probably if
interest rates are going up next year
um we'll see them rise to somewhere
between one and two percent
that is still historically very low in
interest rate terms you might remember
before the financial crisis they're
around about four or five percent
so um as long as people are prepared as
long as these moves in interest rates
are well communicated um i think it
shouldn't be too much of a shock for the
economy andrew i remember uh interest
rates being at 15 that's how old i am uh
it's good to talk to you thanks very
much indeed for joining us andrew thanks
a lot thank you
did you know that if we all work
together we can really make a difference
to the air pollution around our schools
yeah we should really do that
there'll be a chilly start to the day in
places especially the windy and showery
north
showers will affect scotland and
northern england during the morning
perhaps extending into northern ireland
at times most other places look dry with
plenty of sunshine in the south gaels
may affect northern scotland
the afternoon we'll see cloud thickening
in the north and west with showers being
replaced by some drizzly rain
looking at the uk's air pollution levels
are expected to remain low but isolated
pockets of moderate are possible in the
karma south
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
now we don't want to put you off next
summer's um
holiday but my next guest is trying to
stop ibiza from being swamped
by snakes
i know a group of volunteers are working
to catch the reptiles and protect
lizards on the island hopefully one or
two tourists as well joining us now is
dean gallagher volunteer snake handler
in ibiza hello to you
good morning good morning tell me what
you're doing
well okay we've got a bigger project
going on it's involving government
agencies primarily
the government
as well as the friends of the earth and
other volunteer groups
um
tim freytag
who lives in the north of the island who
makes traps
and
basically what we're doing we capturing
snakes
from areas which have high populations
of snakes now one thing i do have to
point out from the very beginning that
the majority of the snakes
are present around the north of the
island in very rural areas they don't
tend to be in
[Music]
highly populated areas because they're
absolutely terrified of humans
and so what we're doing is we're making
traps at a very low cost and getting
them out to rural villa owners and uh
with
mice inside which which are safe
the snake is lured into a hole in one
side of the trap and then just stays
inside the box and then we go and
retrieve them
so tell me about horseshoe whip snakes
what they look like and are they
dangerous
no this is the thing that we need to
make absolutely clear
in some press they've sent centralized
so much and made up the snake out to be
something vicious and terrible and
dangerous towards humans this is not the
problem um the problem with the
the horseshoe whiplash show me the snake
well the one i have at the moment is not
a horseshoe rip snake this one is a it's
called a ladder snake but it's one of
the the two invasive species okay so um
this one here you can see it's a very
young one okay
um it doesn't like being handled too
much but you can just see it's
you know it's perfectly handable
um
if you pick these up by mistake and it
gives you a little nip they're not
dangerous perfectly fine
and um yeah i mean in some parts of
europe they keep these species of snake
as uh
as pets
because you know they get used to the
handler
and they actually like being handled
after a while
but the problem is not the uh
interaction with the humans it's a
problem it's the interaction with the
local endemic
species lizards aren't they tell us
about the lizards
okay i'm just going to put him back in
the box because he's a little bit yeah
yep no problem with that thank you he's
been handled quite enough today so yeah
back in his box
there you go
right so basically we we have um a very
popular wall lizard which is the symbol
of avifa
and these they are they are endemic they
cannot you cannot find them anywhere
else in the world
and some of them are blue in color green
in color and some of the little islets
they go darker blue
now the problem is that the invasive
species snake the
namely the uh headed or the horseshoe
whip snake can actually swim
so it's been known to swim out to these
little islets and it's wiped out whole
populations of subspecies of these um
they be for walleyes
um then the other lizard that we have
here is the um the moorish gecko
they're a little safer because they've
got these
kind of padded feet with lots of little
hairs on they can climb the walls and
stay on the ceiling so they're kind of
safe from the snake
but the beef
wall lizard the green one isn't so lucky
unfortunately because the
habitat is inside the walls and inside
the grooves of the rocks
and that's exactly where the snake get
into and find them
okay
we are suddenly out of time but that's
absolutely fascinating stuff i'm glad
you are doing that job and then we can
come on our holidays and not have to
worry about it it's good to talk to you
thank you very much indeed
thanks a lot much appreciated thank you
what would you do if somebody smacked
your bottom fascinating reply from the
trade secretary next
[Music]